ein anderes gewohnt also man muss sagen
das frisst echt verdammt viele items
also richtig viele items dieses
erforschen ich verbrenne hier gerade
irgendwie meine ganzen sachen also was
ist verbindlich weil die umgebung trägt
einer der der wolf vielleicht und wolf
ist es auch nicht fremd und beginnt soll
ich manchmal einfach wieder mit den fans
kämen hier alles klar
auch meine akkus auch jeden moment alle
vor fakes kam halt so ich habe jetzt
zwei stunden am stück aufgenommen von
daher okay das ist dann anständig wenn
ich hab auch keine webcam einer kennen
oft nicht so unglaublich packen muss ich
mir irgendwann auch mal eine neue face
klamm einfach holen dich dann einfach so
offen bildschirm drauf pumpen können
also durchaus auch so viele ärzte
einfach mitglied noch kriegen kann
von daher fragt euch nicht weil ich dann
endlich raus gehen aha exchange ist es
doch ich wusste es mehr mut für die
frage ist wo krieg ich das haus irgendwo
danach kann nicht im transmutation kann
ich dann machen ok alles klar sollte ich
begebe mich richtung ausland
also ich will auch dieses team nutzte
einem anderen denk ich mal was zu essen
mit zaubern weil ist ja echt immer nur
noch eine folge also noch 14 minuten
weil danach was auch wieder genug mit
dem vor ort aufnehmen finde ich möchte
dass sie eigentlich nicht so viel auf
dem jetzigen die spargel vor der 40
prozent vor auf ausgenommen hat der kann
da jetzt gar nicht mehr so auf die
ganzen kommentarschreiber eingehen sagt
jetzt habe ich die transmutation sehr
geil
manchmal lernt das hab ich was sie
gelernt das heißt ich kann drei kinder
gibt's machen aus so einen quatsch ok
alles klappt
genug gezaubert für heute und es ist
immer noch nachts verdammt ja aber jetzt
so prima drauf deswegen kann man nicht
pennen gehn
nur weg hier draußen trade alle was ist
tag und nacht über alles gas wie überall
ist raus
ja wo radio ich habe mir ich hatte doch
alles voll mit erde gemacht lange
aufnahme wams weit ging in dieser strahl
dieser ein ich habe einmal geschossen
mit meinem ding und der ging 27 blöcke
weit alter der geht normalerweise nicht
mehr als 16 hätte fast noch start sein
grundstück weggebissen
dass sie überall holzes im untergrund
wie heißt das noch mal was da genau auf
sein geschäft ist einfach so etwas haben
wir hier eine kultivierte drohne
fantastisch und eine baldige prinzessin
vielleicht weil die prinzessin mit einer
gemeinen grone alles klar
in meiner allerdings ein anders mal
nachschauen oder kleinere technische
schwierigkeiten
allerdings man anders mal hingehen weil
jemand inventar ist relativ voll
dann wäre ich ein wasser einmal
mitnehmen was ich denn jetzt weg ich
weiß gleich eine spitzhacke weg die wm
da will ich sagen wirklich einfach
schnell den grundstein in dieser folge
etwas länger die folge und setzte aber
noch mal schnell wie gesagt den
grundstein damit ich auch einen haus
habe ich habe ja bisher gar nichts ich
habe nur den keller und das war's das
ist bisschen wenig für energie aber was
bringt mir energiewende ich keinen platz
zum schlafen hab meiner energie kann ich
nicht schlafen acht das ist eine
schlucht so in der ich hier drin wenn
die kinder dann komme ich ja auch direkt
wieder raus das gut 8
also jetzt ist mein grundstück auf
vollständig eingezäunt so dass es schön
ich glaube ich werde den zaun auch weg
machen oder
ich glaube deine idee gefällt mir ganz
gut hab ich dir kopieren will ich
eigentlich gar nicht welche idee eines
wird bei mir sowieso gar nicht gehen mit
der mauer das jetzt hoch setzen weil man
jetzt auch so viel routine
auch hier ist alles so ich denke ich
werde hier alles mein ganzes grundstück
ist generell ein zu hoch und sieht doch
ganz komisch am bau bei allen stiefel
ein
da haben wir dann auch hier sollte
reichen neuer wegpunkt schlucht hast du
dich dieses fiete wies geschmack ist das
so weg.de einfach nur sozusagen
gedankenverloren mit uns selbst richten
das ist das ist aber typisch einfach
wenn wir uns mit dem ganzen beschäftigen
hier dann dann ist das auch einfach so
wir nehmen jetzt quasi nur auf da weise
nicht man kann auch alleine aufnehmen
aber zweites über interessanter da macht
mir spaß sieht hässlich aus auch hier
ist die schlucht direkt 0
ich glaube zurück damit die ganzen
sachen sortieren dann dürfte ich dann
eventuell der mensch weiter nutzen
doch weil ich habe das ja noch nicht so
recht energie speichert sich ja sowieso
also neuer von daher okay danke schön
und dann werde ich mich dann nächste
folge an das solarpanel setzen wäre ich
heute noch bock habe ich werde aber
wahrscheinlich keine zeit mehr haben
dann nehme ich noch auf ich habe jetzt
allerdings auch bald wieder klausurphase
alter erwachsen relativ schnell blumen
ich habe zwar bald wieder klausurphase
anfang juni deswegen werde ich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen was im
voraus aufnehmen und dann werde ich mich
dann um solarenergie kümmern et cetera
macht auf jeden fall zur zeit relativ
viel bock mega projekt wird auch relativ
viel davon kommen und das noch mal ganz
kurz um von meiner position aus
richtig so ich werde mir jetzt erst mal
massiv stein also ich glaube ich kann
mir das mal so 10 stakes stein oder so
was bringt es eigentlich wenn ich im
pflaster steinmeister rating natürlich
samt ausland ok wird der priorisierten
das ja so fantastischen gerufen das geht
so schnell man guckt er auch gerne zu
das so schnell geht irgendwie weiter
aufgefallen zuerst in die ganze sache
die ich nicht bei der entwicklung muss
ich werde mir gleich auf jeden fall
diamant schau gerade mal ich mache mir
jetzt nämlich weil ich so viel war mit
ziegelsteine einfach ganz entspannt beim
empfang ich nämlich an mir so ein
kleines ziegelstein häusler zu wollen
die frage ist wie ich beginne
geb ich dir gleich mal die acht redstone
zurückliegt von der hatte hesses tag so
ja wenn gleich wieder noch dass ich
hoffe einfach mal zu den noch und gibt
den red sox und kann sein dass jeden
moment meiner facetime ausgeht weil ich
halt keine chance mehr habe also das
läuft ja erstmal fantastisch also
ziegelstein ich werde jetzt wirklich
häufig wenn jetzt sehr gut so da bist du
geschützt das kann ich dann gleich an
wenn du fertig bist du von mir aus
vaters couscous ich habe ihm verbracht
wie du schon zwei stacks von dem stein
wird nun vor aus rein tun gutes team
fände ich bin auch ich will nicht
schreibt in einer minute pendent
schreibe ich geh sofort ich klicke nur
gerade ganz drauf rum
alles klar
komm sofort du musst etwas ist das ding
da dann geht die ganze zeit in der wahl
auf dich ja ok die ganzen items sie da
unten sind sind mein okay nicht was ihr
den zaun zu gebaut
darüber muss durch ausgang der firma
wirklich alles richtig zugebaut seerecht
komplett stark 55 brücke zwischen den
einst so eine burg brücke müssen wenn
ich mich so dass ich bin ja eher auf
einer höheren hören dann kann ich da von
mir einfach so weg machen der dann
drüber geht warte ich zeigte das gleich
mal ich schau mal ich man kann auch
teleporter bauen wie der teleporter wie
baue ich den neubau mir später einen
teleporter einfach eine brücke finde ich
in die idyllische report als ob die sich
faultiere vorbei jetzt ist mein akku
alle das heißt festland erfährt aus
hier werde ich mir wahrscheinlich in
unseren kleinen vorgarten machen wir
hier neun mal neun das sollte denke ich
reichen dass sie einfach schon mal
provisorisch hier die dirt blöcke wo
auch noch etwas hin soll sowie sollen ob
die bienen armee wenn ich schon immer
werden dann richtig kommen dann hier
alles voll sorgt eine bienen armee
wie labil
wieso wachsenden pflanzen die bin sauer
auf wenn hier die ganzen boden zu
verbreiten
es geht so nicht so schaut mal arbeiten
wir alle fleißig heilige königin baldige
königin in meine königin und gemeinden
können was ich komisch findet der
diamond drill der baut gras blöcke
langsamer ab als erde ja gegenteil ich
irgendwie das ist offenbar gewollt also
ich glaube aus dem grund weil man ja
munter sudan auf erde stößt und nicht
auf glas und sozusagen wir deine sinne
paris oder also das kann man auf jeden
fall nicht in den dienst tun
das kannst du nur ein schmerz- oder auch
nicht
ich habe muss ich mich auf den eingang
überlegen wie ich das mache das ist
nicht ganz so schön vielleicht manchmal
ganz vl es um teleporter einfach so vom
haus so fünf blöcke tiefer das wäre geil
das ist gesehen was ein experte in der
gruppe gepostet hat sie hat das einer
gemacht hat oder das so der allgemeinen
sogar drin ist wie kann ich einen
teleporter machen die teleporter nehme
ich mir als nächstes vor würde aber
sagen ich hab ja alles da ach da bekommt
man quiksilver raus ja ich habe hier
einen zaun von dir den schweiß einfach
mal in dieser form von dir ganz behalten
habe ich so viel dass ich richtig edel
außerdem texture pack so richtig schön
burg mäßig passt irgendwie nicht zum
ganzen bienen und honig zeugs aber
wieder aufladen
denn er ist täglich so schnell leer so
unangenehm
ich habe nicht mehr zu essen
so warte wie man die kiste
die eisenbahn und ruhe
das sieht schon mal nicht schlecht aus
wenn ich hier so arbeiten dann würde ich
auch sagen manchmal auch von den lehrern
hier die stufen
ganz klar wird schon die ganze busse so
aus die dann alles 12 tick tack und den
marvel lassen wir natürlich aber das
wird richtig sexy glaube ich das wird
richtig 6
viel gebaut so etwas chili gefolge
bisschen bauen ein bisschen chillen
knacken
ich hab meine kisten sind bisschen
ganzen herz einfach in eine kiste
das geht gar nicht
er baute er richtig schnell ab aber nur
erde wandert nicht
er will im mini millisekunden emily sie
kontakt aber glasklar sie mit der faust
crazy daisy dieses mit travel den kreml
auch ganz normal etwas schneller muss
man schon zugeben aber ein anderes
gewohnt
das bringt wieder jetzt quiksilver
eigentlich spark war das letzte mal
sogar ist gerade so geil drauf
ich glaube das kann man gar verzaubern
dass er ziemlich geile elemente es hat
was da ja das hat gute elemente kann er
kurz mal schauen für was braucht man das
hier elemente wahrscheinlich deswegen
einfach nur erst wert von uns allen die
elemente so günstig bekommen und jetzt
sagt er verkauft ja aber nicht nur